watching a professional baseball player
play that must be incredibly tense when
you're when you're emotionally involved
with the person I watch baseball and I'm
not that involved yeah I mean I'm
involved as a fan of my team but what's
it like when you were watching your
husband at the plate and you know I was
I was not the most low-key wife that's
for sure I think I mean I would have
imagined that I would have been like a
little classier at most times but I mean
there's people can see some terrible
things I mean they're like your husband
terrible I wish him dead is the worst
guy ever and I mean my kids hear that
all the time
get used to it they got a thick skin
yeah they say mom we know it's different
heckling at home but from strangers I'm
like no I mean like can you really go
out there and do what these guys do I
know I'm fascinated I mean I'm just
amazed at what these athletes can do
when someone can throw a you know hit a
ball that's coming at you close to a
hundred miles an hour it's moving in
three dimensions yeah and then people in
the stands eating a hotdog it's actually
a really terrible moment which I am
gonna go off a little bit and probably
terrify everybody that's producing the
show but one time Nick came off this the
field and he was very upset we were in
Oakland which was his original team and
he was very upset and I was like why are
you so upset honey and I was just proud
as punch behind home plate
enjoying glasses of wine I had a nick
had a great game and he's like you
didn't hear the chance in the outfield I
was like I'm sorry what and he was like
the entire outfield was chanting
Joanna's average weight they were saying
yeah what are you talking about so they
can be mean to the wives well also in
what world are you average that's insane
I know it's in Auckland 11 everywhere
[Applause]
so I'm never leaving okay might resent
your down to earth yes that might have
been yeah yeah yes I really wanted to
tear me down yeah experience I could
tell the second he revealed it to me he
was like I should not have told her that
she did not hear right a chance it's
just you know oh yeah three out of three
or four or whatever it was that day I
was just proud as punch right but no
apparently I was very average yeah yeah
no they were just trying to get to him
psychologically yeah that's what the
crabs do to me in the monologue they try
to get to me you know nothing I'm in
there I'm talking the on your like your
ugly I hear that all the time that has
ridiculous and I have to make a fight my
way through there's just as many people
in here that think you're the bee's
knees that was happening over here I
feel like every time I come here we have
that moment we're like what's my earring
just fell out your earring just for that
I'll hold on to it don't worry about it
that's mine
you